I discovered his work two years ago
when I was preparing an exhibition on
ceramics so he was really
one of the essential artists of the
great ceramists of today is therefore
I proposed his projects to the Paris currency
and this exhibition therefore takes place today  today
it is also an interest of the currency of the
country of years the speed of the artists who are
able to renew certain gestures
so for example that the amps work with
ceramics as a really
very old material but through his gestures he
completely renews the way  to
process and this is where we are interested
because if our craftsmen here is the new
every year really the gestures and the
know-how thus a traditional way to
give
life to new creations
the three moore that have come
to mind since  a little straight away these
are the words that in fact are the
subtitles of this exhibition therefore vanity
identity sexuality identity because the
work of the grisons perry  is really
very simple and on the different
vanity identities because there is a
very important series of very beautiful
tapestry that crests the theme of
vanity today what does it
present it sexuality because especially
at the beginning  of the career of the grisons have
perished the iconography been explicitly
sexual and sexuality also is part
of these works of his work of his life
so these three words are really a
synthesis of all his work of his entire
career
mallet role of curator i must
to admit it's really
fascinating work for this exhibition in
particular it was really
fascinating work because the exchanges with
the artist were really very very
rich general the roles of a
curator of the exhibition consist in
choosing
an artist  an exhibition not this
nati mandate it can also be a
group exhibition and then told a
story so try to show in
all the complexity the work
of a  rtists in these cases it
was a question of really recounting the
career - thirty years of debris have perished
and of the sadness to count in a way that is
both profound but also easy for
you to show all audiences
so you must never forget  the audiences
we welcome who can be
intellectual art historians but
also young audiences of children of
all ages so the interesting
thing is really to work first
but live them with the artist
interpreted his work  but making them
at le mans accessible to everyone
this motorbike you see is
actually a real stuffed harley davidson motorbike
that belongs to the artist and it kind of
becomes the symbols of the new
masculinity this photo is a rosé one
blue there are words is picked at
channelview militate and if they are the
two words that you don't necessarily think of
when you imagine winter
bikers bikers dressed in black leather
offers a new type of
capable men too  to buy a motorcycle like
this able also to speak about his
own feelings of evidence weakness
to admit that sometimes he is afraid and that
sometimes she is perhaps not able
to assume all the challenges and therefore moment
a completely different vision
compared  to man
via the island where the whole patriarchal system
that the artist with his furniture and thresholds
to change
evidence is absolutely funny and it's a
little different precisely compared to
all the rest of the exhibition
so there it s  acts especially in
the exhibition of voices of
as much as his friends that
bronze tapestries and a motorcycle
he asked the British to
send him photos of how he saw
the amazing thing is that  the
photos were very similar
so in fact the British even if
we then cast a vote which
completely split and the
netherlands mans 1-2 in fact they see the country there
in the same way that's why  '
he decided to make zes so they
repr  present the supporters of the book of
the identical image so same size
same shape same color because that
's how finally the British
see the country
it's very difficult to understand
which ones are dedicated to the people who
voted the  pound for pound the people
who died for the mine
I really like these two vases because
they are in a room that is
very important for the artist so a
room that I decided to call
hospitality and it is a  general a
history that speaks double excites but
also the england
of britain before and after these
date very very important so there is a
more general reflection the
deepest orders
today britain
general europe makes  stormy face major
socio changes that all states
have to face
up when a story the story
of a character through all
strata of British society so
since his birth in a family  he
working class single parent
until his death at the end following a
car
accident once which thanks to the money he was able to
access the place we really see
all the symbols of British tastes
through his
very tapestries  very rich in detail and which
also represents a criticism in fact of
English and British society
because our character in the end even
if thanks to the money he reached the
hype 6 equally aristocratic mood
finally it is in saint saulve  social
at least in england at least a little
present perrine does not really work
its leaders perhaps the best
known series is also stronger
to express my view
that others have on
british society really spent hours
as we did  in front of
the old grocery store it's like a
tale but a modern tale
of today so both there are
references to old painting but
you can also read it in relation to
different  levels
so that's also the wealth the
work force of grézan pays it can
be interpreted in several ways I
will be looking at the beauty the color or
otherwise spend hours to understand
and analyze
every detail